[explosion]
Lord Almighty.
I have to go
out of town again.
What's going on?
I can't really say.
So is this how it's
going to be from now on?
Are you keeping secrets
from me all the time?
Amy, everything is fine.
I promise.
The night this
took place, what
exactly was the first
thing that you remember?
Well, the monster--
[screaming]
--it had these big round eyes.
We saw parts of the spacecraft
scattered all around.
[shouting]
One of them must have been
the engine because it was
still glowing when we saw it.
That was that.
That is part of
the alien spaceship,
or as Sara called
it, the Red Diamond.
So where are we going, Missy?
Well, there is this one place.
They read poetry
and smoke reefer.
I don't know
what to say, Mamie.
You are my kind of girl.
I have a date I
need to get ready for.
Perhaps you can make yourself
useful while I'm gone.
Yes, ma'am.
I'll leave you the address.
Don't be sloppy.
You don't like it here.
It's just so--
Different.
You just need to loosen up.
You just need a little help.
Maybe you should
tell me what you want.
Stay here.
I'll be right back.
Want to feel all right?
Don't be shy.
The red streak across
the sky does point
to something extraterrestrial.
Lord, I knew it.
It was a meteor.
But what about what we saw?
A meteor can't explain that.
We have what we need to write
up a report and close the case.
- Oh, not everything.
- Oh, you found a meteor.
What more we looking for here?
Something to
explain the creature.
You read the case file.
There was one other witness.
We told Evelyn
you were coming.
But I'm not sure
what you'll get.
She still thinks Lincoln's
president sometimes.
Miss Myers, is
this what you saw?
Yes, that was it.
It showed me the
end of all things.
The others that came to see
me before you believed me.
The men in hats,
they were scared.
So should you be.
There's gotta
be an explanation.
[screeching]
Oh.
Good luck, Captain.
We have just found
the Flatwoods monster.
You've all heard the
story about what happened
in the woods that night.
Nothing more than
a great horned owl.
Take a good look,
and the only logical,
scientific explanation.
[crowd murmurs]
Excuse me.
Hello!
We need to make one more stop.
He told me you'd be back.
He left this for you.
How does he even know me?
He only knows what
you want, the truth.
Look, Professor,
you're still new to this.
So let me give you the
answer to the exam, OK?
Spaceships, aliens,
all this stuff
we're asked to
investigate, the Air Force
knows they don't exist.
There is nothing that
can come out of that sky
that you or I can't explain.
Is a meteor all that we found?
At the site, it seemed
to me there may have
been something else removed.
What's under the tarp?
You know, if I could just
take a look for my research.
Your research is
now our research.
Gentlemen?
Sir.
I think the doctor
will perform his role
rather well, don't you?
There's something
off about him.
- Hello.
- (ON PHONE) Good, I caught you.
Craig told me you had a
question for the generals.
Ask me first, OK?
That'll make both their
lives a whole lot easier.
OK, Captain, whatever you say.
Eric, so tomorrow, see
you bright and early.
The consequences
of our actions impact
every man, woman, and
child on the planet.
It's up to us to make sure that
their fate is in good hands.
[music playing]